guillaume la scuderia ce merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes consultant militaire
pour france 24 comment on négocie un
couloir humanitaire pour une vraie mise
en oeuvre et que ce soit pas seulement
de la communication alors tout d'abord
un couloir humanitaire c'est une
exigence c'est une exigence puisque la
convention de genève le précise il faut
et le droit international humanitaire le
rappelle il faut garantir justement la
possibilité pour les civils d'être
évacués et de permettre l'acheminement
des aides de vivre et dans certains cas
même de médicaments pour soutenir les
populations qui sont assiégés qui sont
finalement innocente ou prises
finalement en étau dans cette dans cette
situation comment est ce qu'on le met en
oeuvre mais il faut qu'il ya une forme
de cessez le feu et c'est bien là le
problème c'est que si le cessez-le-feu
n'est pas n'est pas respecté le corridor
ne peut pas tout simplement s'ouvrir
parce qu'il faut bien qu'il y ait des
axes il faut créer véritablement des
couloirs à la fois d acheminement et de
sortie et que ces couloirs soit à la
fois il garanti par les assaillants et
les assiégés et là manifestement le
problème qui se pose c'est que ce cessez
le feu ayant été violées et bien les
corridors ne peuvent pas s'ouvrir et
donc on a une situation qui va devenir
encore plus tendue puisque dans le
reportage on le précise et bien
effectivement la tension augmente sur
les populations qui sont assiégés une
population qui est importante et le
corridor il ya une troisième vocation si
on évacue les populations civiles
c'est-à-dire que ceux qui restent à
l'intérieur ne sont plus finalement des
civils mais bien des militaires et donc
deviennent des objectifs qu'il peut être
légitimement possible de viser mais là
on imagine mal que ce soit les
ukrainiens qui est pas respecté le
cessez-le-feu c'est toujours très
difficile de savoir en fait qui fait
quoi ou qui est responsable de quoi on
est hélas pas sur le terrain et comme on
n'a pas cessé de le répéter ces deux
derniers jours le contrôle de
l'information qui devient aujourd'hui de
plus en plus critique c'est peut-être
une des choses aussi qui va manquer
assez rapidement c'est l'état des
réseaux de communication quand vous
n'avez plus ni eau ni
ni chauffage bon là c'est très embêtant
mais quand vous n'avez plus
d'électricité vous ne pouvez plus non
plus hors charges est tout simplement
les batteries vous ne pouvez plus avoir
les moyens aujourd'hui par lesquels on
communique et ça nous rendra encore plus
aveugles militairement voit bien là
dimur poutine est prêt à tout il cherche
qu est-ce qui cherchent actuellement le
rapport de force pour contraindre à une
négociation globale qui soit dans les
meilleures conditions pour lui pour lui
ensuite je suis pas dans la tête de
vladimir poutine et sans ne cesse pas de
le rappeler mais il ya une réalité qui
étaient rappelés dans le dans les
échanges qui ont été rapportés par
l'elysée entre le président de
république est bonne macro et venir
poutine dans lequel poutine finalement
disait qu' il ne serait pas avant
d'avoir finalement rempli tous ses
objectifs
lesquels il n'a cessé de les rappeler
lavrov est revenu lui aussi dessus est
ce que l'on peut dire cela dit c'est
qu'effectivement on voit mal réduire
poutine pour l'instant cd ou avoir
l'impression de perdre la face la
question de savoir qui doit céder et
avec quelle ligue 1 on peut
véritablement pouvoir négocier
traditionnellement on négocier en
position de force et non pas en position
de faiblesse et on peut voir que la
prise de marioupol c'est une ville
importante pas simplement pour sa
vocation stratégique mais parce que elle
bloque aussi toute la mer d'azov et
qu'elle donne une percée significative
et une continuité territoriale entre le
don de basse et la crimée est bien là ce
serait finalement un un levier à partir
duquel on pourrait commencer
certainement de discussions mais est ce
que c'est le seul est-ce que c'est
l'unique je serais bien en peine de lire
vous pensez qu'il ya des contacts entre
la population est chrétienne et les
soldats russes actuellement sur le
terrain alors c'est là encore très
difficile à dire on est on je pense que
il est très difficile de dire mais si on
reprend par exemple ce qu'on a vu à
ersonne où la population justement
manifestent devant les les bâtiments
publics et les édifices qui sont tenus
par les forces russes en montrant le
drapeau lorsqu'on a des images qui nous
sont rapportées où on voit justement ces
populations civiles qui sont qui
invective véritablement les soldats
russes on a aussi dans l'autre camp la
manière dont les ukrainiens
instrumentalise les les prisonniers de
guerre russe et on voit bien en fait ce
rapport de force on est dans un narratif
qui est extrêmement important à mettre
en oeuvre et à observer de manière
presque froide des contacts oui il y en
a forcément n'est pas forcément parce
que justement il n'ya ses contacts entre
les soldats et la population civile
entre les forces armées ukrainiennes et
les rudes et les forces russes ne serait
ce que parce que quand on ce combat à un
moment ou un autre on se bat aussi les
yeux dans les yeux merci beaucoup lié
aux menaces quand j'avais la scotch
arias pour votre héritage merci